am i gonna win some money if i eat all
this
what kind of money i'm gonna win
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by derek lewis he's a
top contender in the ufc's heavyweight
division and there's not a single
fighter in the weight classes history
with more knockouts on their resume and
he's celebrated for his sound bites
almost as much as his power will he keep
his pants on today if the sauces get too
hot i guess only time will tell derek
lewis welcome to the show thanks for
having me see that was pretty good you
did pretty good you're way better than
me i'll take that i'll take that and you
know texas boys they've traditionally
done really well on this show how are
you around spicy stuff i love spicy food
my wife already knows that once i start
eating spicy stuff she already know get
the the baby wipes ready
there's going to be some screaming in
the bathroom but i like it though
[Music]
it's already on there it's already on
there man we should have switched place
then will you want to switch no sorry
you already touched it
so this one yep that one right there
[Music]
we're always interested in how a fighter
gets their start and this rose growing
in the concrete profession of mma and
then i know that you started off
training as a boxer but saw a faster
more direct route to making money
through mma they're obviously both very
hard ways to make a living but what did
you see is more difficult about the
boxing journey
um the boxing journey is like it seems
like you got to train a lot more you got
to do a lot more cardio and running and
stuff like that i'm not with all that
you know with that um so mma to me is
like emotionally like street fighting so
it's like you do everything you want
instead for pulling hair and hitting in
the nuts so
i'm down with that and then i often
times talk to fighters especially early
on about shady promoters or managers
what's a lesson about signing contracts
or getting paid up front that you had to
learn the hard way i miss a lot of shady
on managers out there and there's a lot
of shady promoters when some promoters
um
you gotta watch in the contract that
some of them
only we'll pay you one dollar
then pay you cash afterwards you know
irs don't like all that so you got to be
careful with that stuff like that and
there's a lot of promoters all managers
out there as well
that would try to screw the fighter over
and
try to take all the sponsorship money
and don't even tell the fighters that
he's being sponsored by someone
[Music]
oh they probably talk about me i'm
telling how to eat chicken wing right
[Music]
mike tyson once put the art of the
knockout into words by saying it's
hitting them with punches they don't see
does that ring true to you and how would
you define the art of the ko
to me it's like
especially knocking out another grown
man it's like one of the best feelings
in the world you ever did it before no i
i don't
it's a care feeling you know i love it
it's addicting
and then why did you say that your
favorite striking technique is head
kicks
um hey kicks is like something i like to
do loosen up
get my nerves out they never seen it
coming from a guy my side so i like
doing it and then what has been the most
satisfying knockout of your career
most satisfying knockout of my career
problems against curtis blaze
blade's been talking trash for three
years straight like no matter if i win
or lose he'll be in my dms or making
public getting known that he don't like
me
i like my style whatever and so
that was so sweet
[Music]
that's good
you know i think uh because you're like
a texas barbecue guy there's like a
little sort of like barbecue with that
with a little honey it's kind of like a
fall oktoberfesty kind of sauce
that's good
so before being convinced to pursue a
career in mma i understand that you
worked as a tow truck driver
obviously you're someone who can handle
themselves in ten situations but what is
the most heated confrontation you've
ever had with someone when you're towing
their car away
probably the most heated thing it was
because we also with aaa we also
like um pop locks like they lock the
keys in the car
so i was like bending the glass back so
i couldn't unlock the car it's like a pt
cruiser um
drop top and they thought i was going to
break the glass and i was just telling
them no i got this i know what i'm doing
and so they were just really like making
sure everything is okay with that car
like i said nothing wrong it's pt
cruising nothing wrong with this thing
this thing's already broken before you
brought it and they said oh you're being
an [ __ ] i said nah i'm serious
nothing wrong with the car i got this
whenever i was tow truck driver i really
didn't care how i grabbed your car
if you wasn't around watching me i don't
care
i'm pretty sure your car was all messed
up
[Music]
anything they got low center i already
know it's gonna be hot
hopefully we can i should have grabbed
your plate when you grind mine
well you know the rest i'm open to that
by the way i'm very i'm open to the to
the switcheroo if you want to do that
you just let me know all right
i'll buy one and you buy one
all right well no no no no no
so i've noticed that you're one of the
few huge ufc draws that doesn't overly
engage in petty trash talk is that just
a coincidence or do you think you
approach the fight game a little bit
differently than the others i approach
it differently most of them guys trying
to be the best fighters in the world and
stuff like that i don't care about being
the best fighter in the world
all i care about is to check as long as
they pay me good
i'm down to fight whoever is there a
rule change that you'd like to see
implemented
i'm probably like the fight week doing
all the interviews because most of the
reporters keep asking the same question
like they all see the articles and stuff
like that but they still want to get
their turn to ask the same question
i hate doing it
yeah
this wing is kind of spicy we can go on
to the next one
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's good
but this one and this one so far is
pretty good all right derek we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham we're doing a deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context which
not from our page right from your page
and let me tell you what a roller
coaster that was i don't know where you
get your memes but you have quite the
collection are there any any good
follows that you can recommend for our
viewers of course lil duvall you gotta
follow duval it's pretty funny well
let's check out more of the conventional
more of the classic derek lewis pictures
we'll pull him up on the monitor what's
the best thing about being a texans fan
and what's the worst thing about being a
texans fan i guess the best thing is
that they treat you good whenever you go
to the games and stuff like that
whenever we lose a lot of guys get off
the bandwagon
saying that
everybody need to be fired
but that's the only thing i don't like
about it is just wish you watching yeah
but not you i'm not no
and then uh you threw out that first
pitch at an astros game
listen yeah the wings are good
yeah so
yeah well let's try this one
yeah what happened was i was wearing
jeans as soon as i was getting ready to
throw a mosquito bit me everybody knows
mosquitoes are bad in texas so it'll
throw that pitch off nothing to be
ashamed of there yeah and there's a guy
yesterday
playing that yankees i think he was from
los angeles something maybe i seen on
the top 10 this morning that he did the
same type of pitch
so you know
i could be a major league and just one
mistake
and then one last one for you what do
you remember about meeting dave
chappelle ufc 264
yeah he's a cool dude i mean i thought
he was taller than
than what he was you know i thought he
was taller than me whenever i seen him
on tv
and he loved his cigarettes yeah yeah
[Music]
let me see man look at that i am see i'm
saying color actually i think of
anything i got more color
[Music]
so back in 2018 you announced an open
invite for people tripping you online to
come to the gym for a fight did you have
anybody take you up on that offer and if
so what were some of the highlights of
the afternoon oh i had a couple of guys
and
i knocked three guys out that week so it
was fun it was fun made sure they signed
the waivers just like y'all had me do
same type of paperwork same
sign the way he was and it was a lot of
fun
it was the guy who came on his birthday
41 years old i didn't care he brought
his wife and his daughter to the gym his
daughter and his wife was videoing he
knocked him out with a head kick in the
first few seconds
his daughter started laughing
his wife said ooh
and i said let me see that video and
this wife said no i already deleted it
but i seen the video from his daughter's
phone and she sent it to the coach and
started watching us yeah that's what he
gets that says his birthday he said he
we didn't he didn't know he was doing
kicking that's what he mean he kicked me
in my leg twice
he said no we need to do that again
that's a 9 minutes your birthday
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah my coach didn't like that dumb he
was worried that there was one soon
[Music]
[Music]
that one was good
whoa
it's a pretty
spicy sauce so when someone's like
that's good with a poker face i'm just
no it's a good flavor to it mm-hmm
that's spicy really good flavor
so you're very vocal about your love for
your hometown of houston not the least
of which when it comes to the food
offerings do you have a go-to order at
mike's seafood
anything you are that might see for is
good anything i promise you you go to
anything you order don't matter what it
is
i don't even like oysters
but there
but there they smell better but i've
never tried them
they smell better i'm sure they're good
i don't like oysters but i'm sure
they're good
what is the turkey leg hut
it's a place a restaurant
that serves big turkey legs that
grab the bone and the meat just fall off
the bone
it's pretty good they put all kind of um
spices on it um
like rice
um i believe they do macaroni and cheese
too they put on top of it
lobster i believe and crawfish i put on
top of the turkey leg it's pretty good
i'm drinking water no
you know it's okay yeah i think i'll go
in too
so this next one is to bomb beyond
insanity think about it with spicy food
you can't let it touch your lips right
because you get the burn you can burn
the burn that's what
makes you want to quit but you know
not today
[Music]
what's good
whoa
okay
now then again
[Music]
yeah
that one's a little different
y'all did that on purpose on that one
it's like someone you know you got
swishing around yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
that one's crazy
that one's crazy
i think it's making it worse now yeah
so when we had t-paint on the show i
know
just chill for a second
[Music]
you may have told me some t-pain yeah
ain't hurting you no it is it is
let's take our time for a second sure
sure let's slow it down
and then just be careful around your
eyes you know if you sweat around your
eyes you'll want to do that but don't do
that because
you'll have spice on you oh y'all got
extra
yeah yeah we have uh fully stocked
lifelines over there
but you already have the ac on though no
no it gets very hot in here actually
okay
t-pain when he was on the show he talked
about the downside of owning luxury
imports what's the biggest pain in the
ass thing about being a lamborghini
owner i guess right now because of
clover the worst shops in italy is
closed down right now
am i gonna win some money if i eat all
this
what kind of money i'm gonna win if i
ain't gonna win no money we could start
right now
dom how much you got on you
dom how much is in the wallet
[Music]
i'll tell you about t
[Music]
what are your thoughts on electric or
self-driving cars like could you ever
park a tesla between two of your lifted
trucks yeah i just brought a model x
yeah i like the electric cars
and i was looking into the porsche
um tycoon those are pretty good too
so you need to tell me
these next two right here are higher
than that
so here's what i'll say here's what i'll
say
i think that if you can get past this
sauce you can get past any sauce in the
world
this is
been in our lineup since the beginning
of time
because it's such a show-stopping sauce
you know you were cruising along just no
problem no problem no problem the bomb
it's always just a hard road block
and the dude over there he probably like
yeah we got his ass now
yeah he just wait they've seen some [ __ ]
they've seen some [ __ ] in here
[Music]
i got big lips too so
oh you know you're supposed to put this
on your lips but try it out
if it works
so if i bump up tomorrow
y'all know it came from this
that might have helped a little bit
actually
you might be onto something here
so in addition to excelling in contact
sports like mma obviously and then
football which i know that you played in
college you also keep the competitive
juices flowing with the occasional round
of golf what drew you to the sport and
then what's the part of your game that
you think needs the most improvement
drew me to the golf sport
because they don't want to always say
that i'm rich and so i said okay i'm
southern where rich people do them so i
started playing golf
and i love it i love golf
it's competitive you know
doesn't matter how long you've been
golfing everybody still sucks every now
and then so i feel right on in
do you have a 19th hole tradition
probably just take some shots take shots
afterwards there you go
so what are you doing
you don't have to if you don't want to
yeah i'm not
we probably was hell in school huh like
the peer pressure and all that
no no some guys don't want to try
shrooms and he's like come on man
it'll be all right they're not that
strong they're not that scared
oh come on man
okay
[Music]
but
i don't even taste like
chicken
but thankfully derek we're out of the
spice woods that's it that's it and just
one more question until we release you
to a cryotherapy session you've been a
highly requested guest on hot ones ever
since delivering that memorable
post-fight sound bite my balls was hot
after taking on the wings of death today
can you describe in as much detail as
possible what's going on through your
mind and body
i actually did wanted to take my my
shorts off
especially with that last two
but
now you know i know what type of show
this is what rate it all
you know i didn't want to do anything
like that though
but i can't even open my mouth
well you know what derek this show it's
whatever you want it to be and today you
took on the wings of death and conquered
and now derek lewis there's nothing left
to do but roll out the red carpet for
you this camera this camera or this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
well
i opened up a beauty salon a few months
ago called beauty marks
we're we're gonna be open up one we're
gonna try to open up one
every year every year until i retire so
that's the goal and also
got a hot shot company going
that's um
that's doing pretty good i have a few
trucks now
and
everything's going pretty good in my
life right now
well i'd like to hear that
great job great job
[Music]
i eat at um firehouse too and they have
hot sauces like this yeah do you ever go
crazy like that or yeah i tried a tin
yeah
yeah how does that compare to like this
oh this
is there
all right
what is up cam fam tis i vampire guy
bill for another hitorious hot ones
unboxing video let's see what's inside
oh a sticker perfect for decorating
one's coffin
and what's this
hot ones classic blue label
garlic fresno edition
now with ten ha ha ha times more garlic
i can't do this i can't do this can we
cut i can't do this
do you see the problem with me doing
this or the sound guy do you see the
problem i'm a vampire that it's garlic
you can do this vampire guy bill you can
do this
[Music]
[Music]
hey
that's delicious
hot ones classic garlic fresno sauce so
good even a vampire will try it only at
heatiness.com